[Musique]
c'est bien dommage de raï est toujours
pour gagner sa vie
mais pour le reste
heureusement merci à vous a fait
rassurant
marais
on
les mineurs sont
le grand ni désormais
mais pour le reste
heureusement merci la vie l'amour ça
fait brasser
j'avais des poulains replier ses drones
a mis cette nuit à manger
et pour le reste heureusement hier si la
vie l'amour n'avait pas assez de temps
[Musique]
on
georges
mon ennemi
pour le reste heureusement
merci la vie l'amour ça fait passer le
temps
il y en aura
à travailler
genève jours pour gagner sa vie
se lever
et pour le rêve
heureux
merci la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]